на президентське крісло у Франції чотири
основні претенденти члени глави держави
франсуа олланд на болото водам з на
інший термін через низький рейтинг
франсуа фійон партія республіканці самий
ціль консерваторам валяються фаворитом
президентських перекладаємо вин сенсації але
за remix президента ніколя саркозі на
праймеріз провела уроку франсуа фійон і
62 несміливим вино пити чай ви вирішите
проблеми зайнятості
прям струму badguy.com та мечами санкції
проти Росії неефективними багатий
експерти називають його лояльним до кремля
і готовому на вчинки нині франсуа фійон
у центрі скандалу політику закидають що
even просила що у свою дружину свою
позначаються і ядуха формально за для від
рима нею бюджетну зарплату
заданим і змій зрозуміла по фійону
вимагала й ноги до 7000 євро на місяць
марін ле пен національний фронт
лідерка право папулей ську партії
активно україна побої у них французі
нових терактів а так уже нотами біженців
заданим і спосіб цього невада виходьте
інші тури може стати перейшов у
історії Франції
президентський її національний фронт за
повстання рук і вдав з
маргінальну політичні сили
модус основних у франції марін ле пен 40
вазі муразе прямого на збирається
викликати онікс розумний український крим
російську територію
так він і називає з розуму манту
російський сансе
їхні очі з косово ти їм вона та macron
впарять 39 особистий екс-міністр економіки
старий президентські вибори руб в
порядку французьку сама лізу я його
initial їм macron стриму до набирає
популярність викликаний майстер та
масивних промок 2016 вона була в
політику мороку
раніше він був соціалістом нині шт
позначена або раннім шим макро нового
зі блеванула не над чи ж звучних
політиків за оцінки мої погляди heaven
травня усі і шанси паси ти ще на і менше
третини міс і у президентських пар гонок
бенуа амон соціалістична партія
до лиж не менше 2 свити на лижі до лівого
крила соцпартії йому 49 років
омона битися і всім французам ще
місячному виплачують і 750 євро після
2020 другом
руку так вже плиток виступає за
легалізацію марихуани
хочеться проводять і падати вікна ви курс
стань у роботі тугу саваний закон про
процом столітті запитайте роботу дав усім
звивини місць євро битники за прогнозами
соціологи барани борються на свої вбити
санки
кандидат ви соціалістів навідний
пробейся в інший туру вигадку експерти
у зручній цій участі соціаліст його
виборах збер їх ти викриваючи те гіпно піт
і
в опозицію перерахунку вибори президента
франції вигляд будете 23 тини інший все
можуть рівня